how do you feel being back in l.a man i
mean i love being in l.a you know
rassan's always bragging about the
weather
and i left good weather to come to
better weather but i i do have to say
rasan i don't know when the last time
you flew was but flying is it's in the
it's a dumpster fire now flying is just
the worst um we brought a bunch of
people out here non-stop like um uh
delays
and packed planes yeah and just like
just i mean
flying sucks now i was in hawaii uh last
week but i didn't have any issues with
my flights um but i did get a little tan
do you like my tan yeah you know i got
my i got one too
here's here's something about flying
that baffles me what's that i have a
seven-year-old son and my wife and
and him and i travel and we always have
to figure out how to tell them to get
our seats at least one of our seats to
sit with him okay so so again i get on
the plane and i get what i uh
affectionately called white trash first
class when you're sitting in coach and
you're on the aisle and somebody's on
the window nobody's in the middle right
so this is going on it's going on it's
going out the plane's delayed and then
they come back and they find out that
there's some configuration of a parent
and a kid on a lap so they throw the dad
and the kid next to me the kid's like a
year and a half old so he sits down
sneezes snot all over the place yeah
then the kids throw in his bottle i'm
picking it up and i'm hand sanitizing
every time but at one point at one point
during the trip the dad was passed out
right and the kid was playing with the
toy and i thought to myself am i now
responsible for this child i think you
legally are it's first-class rules
um well imagine if they just put the
baby there without the parent well do
they do that do they sit your
seven-year-old they eventually always
figure it out at first we went to mexico
and had he was three and we had to tell
them he can't sit by himself and they
were like we don't know if we can do
anything you have to do something right
it's like you want to take care and then
so yeah so imagine if we're just like
okay nico we're just gonna sit you here
so this is what happened on my flight
this empty seat was there the flight
attendant then inevitably the ticket
agent came up to me and they kept saying
have you seen anybody here and i'm like
no they're are you sure and i'm like no
they go are you positive like i'm not
hiding someone no one's here so it
turned out
wait what
it was it was parents and a
three-year-old and a one-year-old i
don't know how many seats they bought
but one of them was supposed to be
sitting there with a kid on their lap
and at one point i heard them telling
the people you can't have five people in
one row because it was the parents the
kids on their last head
and another person but that delayed the
flight a half an hour
you